what does this do press to operate
[Music]
okay here we go
ah okay here we go is this licorice is
that what you call this is this the
English one
[Music]
yeah
oh that's disgusting I'm not gonna I'm
gonna put in here
that is disgusting
I can't swear can I that's disgusting I
used to love toxic waste do you ever
have so many toxic waste that you can't
eat anything for about three days
afterwards you've burnt your mouth off
oh God that is better
could I keep this I think that's really
better
poison X which is the winner oh the
toxic waste would you wear
no
next please
much sweating a bit about a Java cake
would you like one sure
it's uh like an orange no I don't like
orange flavoring things
I actually don't don't know
I have no orange flavored things try it
though it's not orange flavored it's
actually got orange in it yeah orange
chocolate
that don't smell right smell it smell it
I want to smell
smell it because it's in my
mouth that doesn't smell very good
you haven't got to the orange bit yet
though oh that's gonna be the worst no
no no you're done it's not it's not my
style
my vibe
Vibe something that you don't want
make out and make this
orange filling okay so what would you
do inside what's the inside of this
orange jelly
it's better looking Tom Holland or who
do you think is the other gun it's gonna
be Timothy chalamay I bet you've put him
up there no because he's double handsome
and I'd lose that one Jake Gyllenhaal
he's also double hands Harry my brother
I'd win that one seriously oh me Mark
Wahlberg that's actually a really nice
picture of me and that's not very
flattering light on Mark there he's
handsome man in person but I think I'm
gonna win this one
any words for Mark enough said really 73
that's pretty brutal what's up guys I'm
and I'm Jake Gyllenhaal we're going to
play First Impressions oh yeah which is
a game where you have to do Impressions
and I suck at them so
jokes on me
I'm doing this without getting on the
floor
[Applause]
come on get me out of it
I'm an animal
I don't know like that makes that noise
octopus no dolphin there you go oh my
God now you know what a good impression
that is what does this do press to
operate
the definition of don't press the big
red button
hey everyone what's up it's Tom Holland
and this is what happens next with lad
Bible
no
oh I think I know what's gonna happen
here A Cat Sits on a broken Xbox looking
extremely guilty the guy opens the door
to reveal that his brother has piled up
20 dirty plates and Al is perched on top
of the Wardrobe and flies into his face
well none of those were the ones I
thought it was going to be I thought he
might catch his brother doing something
he shouldn't be doing all should be
doing
it's Up For Debate we don't know he does
look like an Xbox kind of guy
I'm gonna go with Xbox a
that would have oh my God
Hedwig was in his room man
what is Tom Holland's best feature oh
this is so embarrassing my height
my broken nose my hair my hair's a good
one I like my hair and I'm going to be
really lame and say my work ethic first
one is oh smile nice
personality I like that muscles we all
knew that was coming but I didn't want
to say that and left toe so we put these
options in and they decided which these
is the best oh I see so I didn't have to
come up with the categories I've totally
just gone off the rails there
that's so embarrassing I reckon it goes
b a
CD
[Music]
b-a-r-d-c personality is great though I
like that just to note that left toe was
more more than muscle than my muscles
I'll try so hard in the gym
I don't know how to do this one okay no
I don't I don't know it's not a thing
okay
it's not a thing I mean it is a thing
but it's not a thing try your best
um
we're in London we're going down the
street to a funky beat oh the uh and I'm
gonna get a haircut oh free sandwich you
can do whatever you want oh
[Applause]
thank you
I'm in London I was like Waiters
all the time no oh
um
[Music]
American football is better than soccer
three two one
yeah I disagree too yeah I don't think I
mean I like American football I just
will never understand very dangerous why
it's called football
because they don't use their feet I just
don't understand why it's called
football yeah it should be causally
different maybe throw ball whatever you
want to call it you don't kick it
you kick it yeah what once yeah
I like American football and I can
respect the athleticism and the
Strategic aspects of the sport but
football
is the greatest sport of all time I mean
it is it is the World Sport and you know
we went to the band all the other day
and we met Messi and it was great
it was crazy and we met on Batman I
actually asked them but hey I said hey
nice to meet you he was really friendly
I said mate you have to come to
Tottenham and you
know
I don't really know what any of that
means but for sure okay
okay
is this what um Woody Harrelson eats in
that zombie film I've always wanted to
try one of these if this is bad I'm
going to be so disappointed oh it's a
bit damp though if you get this
oh that looks minion
[Music]
what is that that's disgusting
can't go wrong with a Jaffa Cake
if your nan doesn't offer you Jaffa
picks if you've been your name I mean
defecate for me
[Music]
again win that one for me
I just love Bible yeah this is the lab
Bible I'm home
I like it when you have like a gangster
come on yeah well that's a very
different vibe today what's it like when
you interview that gangster though
terrifying yeah thank you that Bible for
watching click around me to do whatever
it is they want you to do I don't know
just
be my biggest fan what is naked
attraction oh it's that show you dirty